jacques albert attabi
très enfants bernardin juvénile secret
quand même un pote au tour de france qui
trient les trucs
toute façon que ça secret je vais pas
vous le dire un jour je vous le dirai
sainrapt des produits un truc ah oui et
puis je vous dirai si vous voulez les
mêmes c'est cher bernard tapie va se
recycler dans l'anti âge c'est ça voilà
un an ce cas ça marche 75 regarde 75 ans
m
voilà bernard d'abord merci d'être là
vous n'avez rien de 20 membres et vous
êtes là par solidarité pour tout le
monde en parle parce que c'est l'avant
dernière émission
il arriva
je sais il a quand même il ya quand même
demandé trente mille euros l'équipage je
signale que personne n'aime les a donné
son nom de jardin non mais c'est vrai
franchement ça fait vraiment plaisir
parce que parce que c'est une émission
qui va manquer beau c'est donc je suis
content de venir avec vous deux à
l'occasion d'un de ces dernières des
voilà merci bien sûr on va parler
politiquement on va commencer avec avec
le foot avec le mondial avec les bleus
[Musique]
oui
alors gare à vous expliquer comment
cette métamorphose des bleus dans le
match contre l'espagne il ya plein de
raisons mais on va essayer de sortir les
essentiels la première et la plus
importante c'est le changement total de
psychologie et de motivation quand on
rencontre le togo la corée même la
suisse
les français ont beau se dire et se le
dise il faut gagner on va mettre tout
notre coeur va mettre toute notre
énergie ils font appel à ce qu'on
appelle la motivation volontaires celles
qui dépendent sa volonté quand tu
rencontres l'espagne ouais et qu' il
s'agit de passer un cap et surtout de
remettre les pendules à l'heure là c'est
tu fais appel à la motivation
inconsciente
celle qui te fait courir le 100 m parce
que ton gosse se noie 1
la vraie différence à s'éclate qui font
ils font appel à des ressources que
seule la volonté ne peut pas de données
alors quand on sait qu'un être humain
utilise à peine la moitié de ses
potentialités
car sur un match comme ça tu obtiens des
trucs bon alors ensuite l'espagne eux
ont vécu le contraire on aura mis la
tête comme ça c'est les futurs champions
du monde ce qui fait que malgré
l'ouverture du score aurait pu leur
permettre de temporiser un peu de jouer
les malades restez derrière évasion de
continuer on continue et ils nous ont
donné des boulevards derrière que les
français ont bien su exploiter ses
énormes c'est énorme parce que on a vu
ce que ça a généré chez les gens c'est
inimaginable
c'est une belle démonstration de ce que
les gens sont capables de faire lorsqu
on leur offre un événement qui met rang
1 bis la toile les gens vivraient en
tous les français sans variété
incroyable sais pas si tu as eue dans
les rues par tours 1 c'était une c'est
un bonheur exprimé sans limite et qu'on
voit pas dans autres dans d'autres
formes d'existence ce que le sport et en
particulier le football moi je vois
jamais des gens qui se connaissent pas
dans la rue qui s'embrassent et la
grande scène ça c'est un quartier où
les boîtes privées oui
alors bernard cette émission est
enregistré exceptionnellement avant
france-brésil vrai puisqu'on est jeudi
soit la voilà donc tu vas me donner un
pronostic
et l'hommage vient de finir ouais c'est
horrible objectivement je ne te juge sa
réputation mer noire parce que je ne
peux que te dire là ce qui va se passer
sûrement un et te dire je souhaite
tellement j'ai tellement envie qu'on
gagne que je te fais pas de pronostics
je te fais que mon souhait ouais ouais
j'ai vraiment la trouille j'ai vraiment
peur parce que réellement sur le papier
autant il n'ya pas une autre équipe
franchement y'a pas une autre équipe qui
nous est supérieure je dis bien sur le
papier sur le papier le brésil nous est
supérieur alors maintenant est ce que
cette espèce de confiance convient de
prendre cette espèce de 2,2 volonté de
ne rien avoir à faire parce que
maintenant ils ont fait l'essentiel on
est en quart de finale contre la ville
celui qui gagnera sera dur à battre le
fait que l'arbitré espagnol
conneries pour nous difficile difficile
forcément il va se manger les espagnols
arbitres espagnols moi je pense que
y'aura forcément à dire sur l'arbitrage
malheureusement tu en sais quoi
commentant la merde parce que c'est le
coucher du soleil c'est quoi
l'oiseau derrière j'ai d un merle mais
c'est génial quant à la tombée du jour
celle bernard il fait le maire j'étais
jure que non
je connais pas les saisons la nature
tout ça tu connais pas sa mère la reine
qui emmerde
bon j'en ai dans mon jardin ici que des
jeunes bourreaux étaient invités
tous les jours et moi je finis la la la
la la la
on est devenus potes
au pensez quoi des condamnations dans le
procès des comptes de l'om marc tapis et
je veux qu'on pense la même chose que
quand elle s'adressait à moi
elles ont strictement aucun sens tu peux
pas condamner robert louis dreyfus pour
abus de bien social dans son club dans
lequel il a mis 130 millions d'euros je
veux dire faut être un peu que 6 de
fresnes qui peut l'accuser plein de
choses éventuellement d'art fait des
contrats bidons d'avoir arnaqué j'avais
l'urssaf que les joueurs et est riche et
sur les impôts je suppose qu'il doit y
avoir dans le dossier des choses mais
ils n'ont pas retenu là dessus donc ça
veut dire qu'il était coupable de rien
d'autre que ça et là c'est du délire on
peut pas reprocher à un mec d'avoir été
puisque le délit d'abus de bien c'est
d'avoir porté tort à son entreprise en
gros en gros tu porteras ton entreprise
quand tu mets 150 millions d'euros dans
les caisses un drôle de mazaugues donc
ça tient pas debout alors à suite si on
veut parler des systèmes qui tourne
autour du foot en france je parle
tous les clubs ont recours aux mêmes
arnaque qui consiste à pouvoir faire des
salaires concurrentiels avec les
étrangers qui paye moins d'impôts voilà
tout le problème est là quand un joueur
est sur le point de venir en angleterre
en espagne en italie ou en france il
choisit un autre pays que le nôtre parce
qu'il est plus taxé alors puisqu'on
parlait tout à l'heure ça va vous
intéresser on parlait tout à l'heure des
pronostics eh bien je vais vous dire
pourquoi la france est devenue un petit
pays de football l'angleterre tous les
joueurs de l'équipe anglaise joue en
angleterre mais qui dit à sauve beckham
l'italie tous les joueurs déclin
italienne journée italie l'espagne tous
les joueurs l'espagne joue en espagne
les allemands tous les joueurs allemands
jouent en allemagne les français trois
joueurs français jouent en france
on a rejoint le peloton des pays sous
développés c'est qu'à cause des impôts
ils sont jugés décevants c'est pas que
ça c'est globalement ses impôts c'est
les contrôles c'est l'urssaf c'est un
pays qui devient pays tellement
pressurisée que les gens ont envie
d'aller ailleurs et ce qui se passe dans
le football ne vous faites pas
d'illusion c'est comme ça pour les
artistes qu'ils peuvent partir ailleurs
c'est comme ça pour tous les autres
sportifs de haut niveau c'est comme ça
pour les grands chercheurs c'est comme
ça pour les grands ingénieurs et ça va
finir par être comme ça partout pour
tout le monde que a plus personne peut
être est il y aura six il y aura ceux
qui veulent un attendent des autres leur
salut personnel mais est ce que cette
crise de confiance envers l'équipe de
france finalement ne traduit pas ne
reflète pas une crise de confiance du
pays en lui-même les français sont très
bizarre parce que il rien sondage sur la
croyance le bonheur et c'est ça qui m'a
vachement épater ses c'est ça dans le
challenge début de l'année question êtes
vous plutôt heureux plutôt malheureux 80
2 % des gens plutôt heureux 4 deuxième
question pensez vous que les français
sont plutôt heureux malheureux ils
pensent que 82% des français sont mal
c'est dément un tournant schizophrénie
total ça veut dire que toutes les
nouvelles toutes les infos qu'ils sont
ce qu'elles sont on va pas reprocher aux
journaux télévisés de dire qu' il ya
tant de morts par le sida qu il ya le
tsunami etc n'empêche que leurs
impressions à eux c'est de vivre au
milieu d'une tempête incroyable rêve qui
fait que tout le monde doit être dans
une merde noire et monde doit souffrir
et pas nous mais c'est pas vrai je veux
dire c'est c'est un des gros problèmes
qui rend ce pays très compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que c'est un pays où il ya
un taux de suicide très important c'est
le plus gros consommateurs
d'antidépresseurs au monde la france
très sain ouais c'est vrai qu'au moment
des trente glorieuses on a eu un modèle
social très développé qui était vraiment
bien bien installés qui était basé sur
le partage sur le fait que tout le monde
doit profiter au moins en ce qui
concerne l'éducation la santé la justice
des progrès qui sont faits et puis ils
ont pris pour beaucoup l'habitude d'être
un peu sponsoriser un peu assisté quand
ils se sentent plus dans cette situation
de sécurité beaucoup perdre les pédales
on est aussi un des pays où le divorce
fait le plus de ravages et crée des
situations dramatiques quand un couple
sans moyens divorce cédé il ya des mecs
qui couchent dans la bagnole parce que
ils ont de quoi payer un appartement pas
deux
évidemment heureusement on laisse la
femme dans l'appartement avec les
enfants et le mec il a plein olmedo donc
en dehors de la souffrance affective il
ya une souffrance matériel terrible mais
il y avait un sondage d'enlever
l'observateur dont on parle d ici la
semaine dernière déjà moi qui me qui
m'étonne complètement c est vous
favorable ou non l économie de marché
alors en chine ses 74 % des chinois sont
favorables à la commune marché aux états
unis ses 71 % dans les grands pays
européens c'est 65 66 % et en france et
34% alors est ce que la france est très
en avance et elle a compris que le
capitalisme s'étaient pas bien et lé
post capitaliste au contraire elle est
très en retard il ya un problème non
mais d'abord il est possible qu'il
existe un système beaucoup plus efficace
plus généreux qui rend les gens plus
heureux qu'on le connaît pas un puisque
pour l'instant on a mis en opposition le
marxisme a généré un socialiste puis une
social-démocratie et puis la loi du
marché bon encore une fois à la loi du
marché pour les gens c'est l'abandon
d'une certaine sécurité et d'une
certaine protection appelait zinc au
monde un pays le plus protégé forcément
les français sont les plus opposés à le
demeurer
ensuite et à l'interprétation qu'on se
fait dans le mot la loi du marché pour
beaucoup la loi du marché c'est la loi
de la jungle et il faut reconnaître que
par certains égards c'est un peu vrai
ouais alors est-ce que le français est
plus malin plus impertinent plus
rigoureux pour exiger davantage c'est un
peu tout ça maintenant il faut que ces
français-là se disent que s'il existe
une autre technique une autre méthode
c'est pas la france qui pourra l'imposé
seul parce qu'elle fait 2 % du monde la
fin donc dans un monde qui est
entièrement soumis à la loi du marché on
est obligé de l'adopter c'est du baratin
alors on a des mecs j'entends besancenot
j'entends tous et c'est bien c'est c'est
rafraîchissant mais entendent dénoncer
ils font quoi il vaut que dal la france
est un peu le village d'astérix
aujourd'hui nombre d'espacés temps
passez vous avez vu qu'il a dit les
patrons faut tous les virer on les
remplacera ouais par quoi par d'autres
patrons 1 qui auront une nouvelle
hiérarchie toute la société basée sur
une hiérarchie que tu tues tu mets 150
mecs sur une plage tuer non et demi tu
reviens il ya un patron il ya deux
adjoints puis elle connard en bas par
rien du tout parce qu'il sait pas quoi
faire et la société doit être bien
organisé parce que celui qui est en bas
il a le droit aussi de vivre ne pas être
piétinée d'être protégé qu'on lui pique
pas son dû pour ubs pas sa femme il a le
droit alors c'est là où la société doit
être organisé pour faire face à la
limite aux aux inégalités de la
hiérarchie mirarchi elle existe dans les
pays socialistes il ya des hiérarchies
dans les pays capitalistes une
hiérarchie la france est un pays qui
s'accommode mal des hiérarchies pays
assez égalitariste la france à ben on
lui a fait sa conception comme ça simple
et logique en tous les cas tout ça donne
aux prochaines élections présidentielles
une importance conseilla blaoui falloir
faire attention programme là parce
qu'après abc moi je pense franchement
qu'on n'est pas dans la situation
dramatique qu'on raconte nom n'est pas
bien et là il va falloir être très
prudent je crois que ces élections là
sont les dernières on a le droit de se
tromper alors vous vous n'avez pas
revenir en politique pourtant vous êtes
éligibles depuis trois ans mais faisait
parvenir est ce que vous avez peur vous
dit quand je voulais devenir maire de
marseille on a trouvé 100 mille francs
dans un jardin pour m'envoyer en prison
l'affairé om va si je suis candidat à la
présidentielle on va mettre son kilo de
cocaïne dans mon coffre peut-être
passant parce que bon cop ne tient pas
mais quelques kilos n'enraye c'est une
manière de dire que on ne veut pas tout
le monde rhin est finalement bon maison
elles ont ils veulent rester entre eux
c'est un métier de faire de la politique
les professionnels al politiques ont
toujours une distance à l'égard de ceux
qui viennent pas de rang mais c'est vrai
de kouchner c'est vrai de borloo c'est
vrai de tapis c'est vrai de tous ceux
qui à un moment donné ont eu envie de
franchir le pas est-ce que c'est
légitime quelque part oui quelque part
louis parce que on n'a pas donné en tout
cas de gages sur la réalité de nos
convictions notre programmation etc par
conséquent on peut croire que on est
capable de séduire sur des éléments
d'appréciation qui justifie pas le vote
c'est pour ça que les électeurs font une
grande distinction entre la côte d'amour
avec des sondages extraordinaire un
kouchner oui le vote 1 le vote c'est une
opinion la cote d'amour c'est une humeur
1 ça nous ramène d'ailleurs à faire
attention aux sondages alors vous
n'allez pas revenir en politique bernard
mais vous allez intervenir d'abord au
nom des trois millions de gens qui ont
voté pour vous ça là c'est parce qu du
sondage la belle humeur et 2010 et des
bulletins dans l'urne et puis peut-être
aussi au nom du parti radical de gauche
non c'est là que je suis parti parce que
c'est la philosophie radicale entre
parenthèses qui est peu développée on a
l'impression qu'il existe plus de 2 mais
le radicalisme c'est justement ces faux
souvenirs c'est gambetta 120 série c
mendès france et l'école publique aux
vins catoire et lapèze séparation de
l'église et de l'état va se veut dire
c'est des choses importantes le daniel
le radicalisme qui privilégie l'homme
plutôt que les systèmes qui met l'homme
au centre de ses préoccupations de ces
débats qui considère qu' un état une
nation n'est forte que par l'addition de
ces valeurs individuelles elle reconnaît
donc la valeur individuelle comme un
élément d'appréciation mais à condition
que les intérêts individuels soient
compatibles avec l'intérêt collectif
normale en termes un peu plus simple ça
veut dire quoi chacun se démerde chacun
essaie d'être le meilleur on doit pas
envisager une égalité par le bas rhin
mais face à la scolarité donc à
l'apprentissage face à la santé face à
la justice on doit tous et égaux le
chanceux le malchanceux l'intelligent le
compte ou le mont si la république c'est
la république c'est la réponse est ce
qu'on appelle la république alors en
2007 vous croyez vous à un match sarko
ségo
prier pour l'instant il est plus que
probable way est vrai que les mecs comme
l'inde comme fabius comme strauss kahn
et 15 ans les mecs qui sont là qui
rament voudrait qu'ils vont laisser
ségolène royal leur piquer non seulement
je crois le bcm est alors là pour le
coup je comprends rien à la stratégie du
parti socialiste rien c'est le contraire
justement de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure du radicalisme l'élection
présidentielle c'est un candidat ou une
candidate qui se présente d'or les
français qui fait une proposition qui
dit voilà la société tel que je
l'imaginé et qui s'entoure des gens pour
la mettre en place le parti socialiste
commence à te dire voilà le programme on
se met tous d'accord sur un programme
dont il est tous d'accord pour dire la
même chose et après comme un casting
comme un film un film tu fais le
scénario et après tu as le metteur en
scène commence à choisir les acteurs
mais c'est de la folie chaque candidat
socialiste à la candidature devrait
faire son programme
passer devant les militants pour que les
militants c'est vrai que c'est un homme
et un programme et non pas pour un homme
ou une femme sur un même programme c'est
ça qui les amène d'abord à dire
n'importe quoi t'as vu c'est golem et
toujours à 1000 même si je vais aller
dit qu'une phrase avait jamais il y en a
pas qui l'attend y en a pas un qui pense
pas
or les sons ségolène royal vendre son
programme celui auquel elle croît 1 si
les militants socialistes en veulent pas
ils peuvent préférer strauss kahn qui
manque pas de qualités qui manquent pas
d'idées ou fabuleuse qui manque pas de
qualités qui manquent pas d'idées et
après par la loi normale de respecter le
vote des militants tout le monde se met
neuf candidats et son programme plutôt
que ça alors ta ségolène qui est pour on
sert un peu la vis le parti socialiste
est là on sert pas la lys ta ségolène
qui est pour le mariage nom déconne pas
on est contre le mariage tu comprends
plus rien c'est du délire
sigolène vous la connaissez bien ouais
elle est sympa après elle parle de blair
mais faut pas vous faire d'illusions
elle est socialiste ait away oui oui oui
vrai de vrai alors ce qu'aime sabah à
lézinnes les mecs et que sarkozy vous
êtes copain bernard non plus non non je
les aime bien ouais je le connais on se
connaît est lui aussi c'est un candidat
redoutable mais lui il est dans une
configuration qui est plus facile parce
que l'ump c'est devenu son parti il est
à la fois
prescripteurs des idées de son parti et
récepteurs de ce que le son parti
propose on dit il va nous faire une
programmation qui en main de ce qu'ils
ressentent et des hommes qui vont le
soutenir pour le faire donc là il est
plus à l'aise pour aller devant les
électeurs que quelqu'un qui va défendre
un programme qui n'est pas le sien donc
je dirais que normalement on a plus de
chance alors c'est peut-être une bonne
ou mauvaise chose chaque français fera
ce qu'il veut mais vous avez plus de
chance de voir sarkozy faire ce qui va
dire qu'il va faire un cahier socialiste
que les socialistes parce que lui il a
cessé son programme et a vu que j'espère
revient puis cette semaine oui j'ai vu
ba dans la même semaine on a quand même
eu les résidents qui a annoncé qui dira
s'il est candidat au 1er trimestre 2007
mais et jospin qui nous dit
officiellement ce qui l'a pas arrêté
nous dire faut quand même dire que ça
fait un an qu'ils nous dit un témoin ou
givet et si vous m'appelez je vais y
aller ouais donc on vous rendez compte
on va peut être assister à une un autre
france-brésil quoi
à la limite ça va être de nouveau le
combat des chefs mais non jospin je
crois qu'il se met hors jeu en faisant
ça ouais il se met pas hors jeu en étant
candidat il se met hors jeu en annonçant
qui peut l'être si on va le chercher
parce qu'il aurait pu très bien ne pas
annoncer qu'il était candidat avant
qu'on le demande et hélas ils avaient
une légitimité quelque part pourquoi
d'abord parce que il croit pas un
instant que ségolène royal est capable
il dit pas qu'elle va pas gagner il
estime tout le monde sait qui la
considère pas capable d'être président
de la république deuxièmement il pense
que les communistes les verts les
extrêmes gauche etc il a à peu près le
seul à pouvoir faire la gauche béria
espèce de gauche plurielle donc s'il
avait été effectivement demandé sans
qu'ils disaient c'était crédible 1 mais
là ils leur demandent qu'on l'appelle
alors qu'on le demande pas je crois
qu'il s'est disqualifiée tu vois que les
gens lui en veulent en plus de cette
barre en 2002 qua non ils lui en veulent
pas de cette barre en 2002 il a eu une
attitude au contraire honorable j'allais
dire digne minimum que tous les
politiques devraient avoir moi le jour
où j'ai été mis hors la politique pour
les ans vous savez je lui suis mise même
si maintenant je suis éligible je
considère qu'on peut pas dire ben attia
je suis fini je reviens il a été porteur
d'un échec terrible il il en a souffert
terriblement il a eu le seul
comportement digne que tous les hommes
politiques n'auraient pas où aller on
vouloir pour ça allons il a été au
contraire ils ont plaire alors
maintenant si dit attendez et finalement
j'ai fait revenir aux alevins - là ça
sent un peu le faisandé quand même alors
tapis vous serez candidat de toute façon
dont le film de fabien onteniente et qui
s'appelle le candidat justement j'ai
adoré ce mec s'est rencontré il m'a dit
qu'est ce tu prêt page d'une pièce
comment s'appelle le candidat il m'a dit
non tu fais un film avec moi 1 il est
vraiment génial donc on va faire un film
ensemble à la rentrée la wii et j'ai
bien aimé son approche il à la jane
bonne idée alors j'ai déclaré j'ai connu
la vie avec beaucoup d'argent je la
connais maintenant sans je préfère la
vie avec et bah ça vous étonne pas tout
est mieux c'est vachement mieux c'est
vachement mieux parce que les gens
essaient de mettre en opposition
l'argent et le bonheur par exemple
si tu me dis tu préfères riches ou en
bonne santé ça suppose que tu es riche
et malade oui je préfére est pauvre en
bonne santé il fait t'es pas obligé
d'être malade parce que tu es riche un
bon we met donc en bonne santé richir
bonne santé forcé mieux en bonne santé
riche mais c'est tout mieux arrêter de
déconner lagarde lagarde en mai vous le
balaur mais vous non mais c'est mieux
d'avoir de l'argent dit bah voila vous
dites maintenant je connais la vie sans
argent ça veut dire quoi et bien d'avoir
un salaire qui correspond à un salaire
de cadre ah oui et pas plus non puisque
tout le reste c'est rigoler
non mais quoi que vous gagnez maintenant
ça ouais et courbis se trouvait qu'elle
était trop lourdement condamné rôle en
tant ils ont mis deux ans de prison ou
placé pour faire un break puis la
récupérer sur six d'avant on a récupéré
dix huit mois j'ai dû faire des choses
vachement grave quand même pour moi rani
n'apprenant rase mission de presse qu'on
donne un type qui violent la rue à
oran que je sais qu'il a dû faire des
trucs terribles et je crois pas qu'il
ait sénart terrible vous l'avez bien
alors oui j'aime beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus